all right
so hello everybody
all right let me set everything up here
so i see two more v's is in the
uh the chat uh seeing him there makes me
want to
announce that on halloween night
at uh on the 31st at 10 p.m
eastern if i'm right two more of these
uh you can uh
you can uh correct me if i'm wrong uh
at ten o'clock eastern on halloween
night
two more of these is going to premiere
the album which is based on my talk
the uh pentecost for the zombie
apocalypse and so
i will be joining the stream as well and
so i've heard a few of the songs
and uh i'm looking forward to seeing
everything that he comes up with i think
that i've shared a few of the songs as
well
but it's going to be a lot of fun it's
going to be happening
if i understand it on on the uh
i forget which channel anyways i will
i'll be posting the link on social media
very soon so
pay attention to my twitter and my
facebook and i'll post it on youtube as
well
in the in the comment section so all
right so looking forward to that there's
a few things
coming along in the um
in the next few weeks very
so you know you guys know i'm on think
spot but i'm not super involved
on thinkspot um
but nonetheless i am going to be doing
an event with
of all people with sargon of akkad with
carl benjamin
uh you know i've since 2016 and when
jordan peterson kind of exploded
we drew attention to a bunch of
youtubers and a bunch of people who were
talking about free speech and sargon is
one of them
i you know he was a very kind of
hardcore atheist and i've seen him kind
of move
his needle be less aggressive towards
religion less aggressive towards
christianity
and so i'm really looking forward to
having a discussion with him and seeing
you know getting a sense of his
perception of the symbolic worldview
and how it affects his his also his
ideas about religion so
i don't have a date yet when that's
going to be put up but we're doing the
discussion next week
i'm also going to have a discussion with
tom holland which i'm looking really
looking forward to that i read dominion
which is excellent you know some just
wonderfully written chapters in there
his chapter on the enlightenment his
chapter
on uh you know the uh that which
the a chapter that talked about the
enlightenment the relationship to the
french revolution
there's also the chapter on kind of
scientific discovery
and ultimately you know the chapters
about communism and just about the
modern world in general
are really really wonderful so i'm
looking forward to that as well
there are some things that i'm not so
sure about if you've read it you
probably could guess whether the things
that i don't totally agree with them on
but it'll be interesting to uh to have a
discussion about that stuff
as well all right so i don't know
if there's something no it's not tom
holland
spider-man it's tom holland the writer
of dominion which is a new history on
christianity
tom he's one of the guys he's let's say
he's one of those people now that is
in a post-secular state where he
realizes the importance of christianity
the inevitability of christianity in our
cultural discourse
and is trying to find his way and decide
where he places himself
on that question so yeah interesting
interesting
interesting character to say the least
all right so
the way this works and as people know uh
people who are on patreon who who are
subscribed at 10
or more get to ask questions in advance
for the q a
and so i will go through those questions
if people put in some super chat i
if if i still have energy at the end of
the uh
the q a i will check the super chats and
see if there's something interesting and
that
i know it's not ideal and some people
complain that you know
that they wish i could answer all the
questions it just seems like
at least for now it's the most logical
it's the the way that i can
you know uh make sense of the questions
or else questions are just too many even
now there's already too many questions
all right so here we go so i'm going to
start on
the symbolic world website
so pluma asks
is there a connection between jacob's
blessing over ephraim
where he says that there that he will be
a multitude of nations
and the fullness of the gentiles that
paul talks about in romans
since the word used for multitude in
hebrew has a connotation of
filling and ephraim is representative of
the northern kingdom which was absorbed
into the nations
making those tribes that were part of
the north
indistinguishable although in the common
translation it at least seems to be
connected to abraham being a father of
multitude of nations
um i don't know about the translation
one of the things i know that's
interesting and this is something
you know once in a while like i pay
attention youtube has
afforded us some interesting things
sometimes it's interesting to listen
to kind of orthodox rabbis or uh
or hasidic rabbis and listen to the way
they talk about things and
if you if you pay attention to the way
they speak about things you'll see that
they often talk about the different
nations of the world
as basically being descending from
abraham in a kind of weird strange
convoluted way
and so they they identify all the
different nations as different aspects
of the different lost tribes of israel
and things and so it's an interesting
cosmology which also you know leads
towards a kind of universal
image of salvation uh something which we
often don't
us people don't associate with judaism
but but i've seen
really seen rabbis talk about it that
way um and so that's
as much as i can say about that
so adam asks so
adam asks hi jonathan in mark 8 22-26
jesus leads a blind man out of the
village heals him and tells him not to
return i can't figure out
why all this about leaving the village
and not returning could you connect some
dots
they come to bethesda and some people
brought a blind man and veggies to touch
him
took the blind man by the hand and let
him outside the village
when he had spit on the man's eyes and
put his hands on him
jesus asked do you see anything he
looked up and said i see people
they look like trees walking around once
more jesus put his hands on the man's
eyes
then his eyes were opened his sight was
restored and he saw
everything clearly jesus sent him home
saying
don't even go into the village
well i think that this is one of the
ways to understand it is
that at least at the beginning you get
the feeling that
christ is wants to remain somewhat
secretive about
what he's doing and so he doesn't want
his miracles to be known at first and so
you can almost see it as a
as a seed that's kind of growing you
know so he starts
small with the disciples does a miracle
with his disciples and then he starts to
do miracles more and more
and he warns people not to talk about
his miracles at the beginning
and then it's as if you can see like a
kind of progressive revelation that
happens through his story
i think that it has something to do with
that there are other places where he
tells people not to talk about
his miracles but that's a really
interesting story that story i was
talking about that today with neil
degrade uh
of dirt poor robbins we were talking
about this story
and uh how it's interesting about that
story is this idea that christ
so he spits on his eyes
and uh you know you can kind of see it
as this water coming from above
that's how i understand it the fact that
he takes the the person
outside the village um
you can imagine it as some the way that
you can kind of see it is almost as if
like he's taking the
the beggar the blind beggar outside the
village so he's manifesting
he's bringing him out into chaos you
could say or outside of the city
and so he's which is manifesting
what he is which is a blind beggar so
he's an
outside figure and so he's taking him to
where he is and then he spits from above
and so he
he sends the water coming coming down
from above like uh
like rain or you know like meaning
coming from above
and that's what heals them but the weird
thing about the story is the first part
where at first he says i see people they
look
like trees walking around and
and then christ has puts his hands on
the man's eyes like
it's like he covers his eyes um
and then his his eyes open up and then
he sees things normally
and so it it's weird it almost feels
like at first his vision was
too high it's like at first he just sees
patterns
see these trees right these patterns
walking around
it's as if christ has to kind of lower
his vision a little bit by
covering his eyes and then he's able to
kind of see
the flesh you know uh it feels like
that's what it is what's going on in
that story but you know
uh it's very mysterious i mean there's
so many things about christ which are
very mysterious so
um all right so david flores asks what
is your favorite monster
and i would have to say that would be
the dog-headed man you know that
i don't think that's much of a surprise
for those who know my
my relationship with saint christopher
you know and so
i would say that's what it is so shay
mckay asks hey jonathan jordan peterson
is back home
in his return home video he mentioned
he's working on a lecture series about
exodus and proverbs
it's in contact with you or your brother
about those
and you don't have to answer this
because it's a second question
wait is the second question i don't ask
two questions you're confusing me
um but he thanked god for his mercy and
grace
i wonder if he had a spiritual
experience and were you in contact with
him during these difficult times
and so i mean it could be a this could
be an opportunity for me to talk about
that
um no i haven't been in contact with
jordan for
for quite a while i would say for
several months now
i i received i had a small exchange with
him while he was i think in serbia
or he was just finishing up in russia um
but it was just we talked about maybe a
future carving that he wanted
and uh that was it but he he said that
he was still
feeling very bad very ill and so he was
struggling to concentrate
and i felt when i watched the video
first of all i was very grateful to see
him and i was
really overjoyed you know and very
emotional to see him appear on youtube
all of a sudden
but i was also i also saw that i could
see that he was still
struggling and i think he still had some
some healing to do
i mean like all you guys i would i would
be looking forward to seeing what he
comes up with
uh with proverbs and i was really
really surprised that he he didn't just
thank god for his mercy and grace but he
said
he said by the grace and mercy of god
like
that's as if that if this is going to
happen by the grace and mercy of god
which really surprised me
because i never heard him speak that way
i never heard him kind of
talk about god directly as something
which is related
to his personal life and so that to me
was extremely
kind of touching and uh gave me hope you
know because i know
like i've been praying for him and a lot
of people have been praying for him
you know in the wings clergy have been
praying for him
and he's been going through some crazy
stuff and he's also
what's the easiest way to say this he's
also been attacked
like he's he's not this is not just
happening
he's also being attacked and so if you
are someone who believes uh in these
things
then then pray for him and pray for his
salvation and pray that
you know praise that his his eyes uh are
opened you know
that's all i can say and that he can see
for himself
all right so c.s treatsell
asks hello jonathan i apologize in
advance
for the semi-long preamble but i think
it's necessary i hope so
these long questions they they they're
not good you need to be able to uh
to synthesize your questions all right
here we go
when thinking about the heaven and earth
dichotomy established in genesis
i started to consider the distinction
between negative abstract higher
principles and negative lower material
principles
for example a fallen angel is higher
more abstract negative principle
i was thinking of it perhaps as an evil
spirit or personality which can manifest
itself in a person's
being via a godless ideology
maybe one that puts power into the
pinnacle of its hierarchy instead of god
there would also be lower material
negative principles such as wild animals
that prey on humans alligators crocodile
snakes parasites yes
or natural disasters etc etc in relation
to each other this creates a masculine
feminine dichotomy
with a category of the evil
is this an accurate way of understanding
the pattern of evil
and if so doesn't this support jordan
peterson do you have ordered known and
chaos
unknown as having both positive and
negative
polarities i've heard you cast criticism
on chaos being associated with
feminine however this seems to be caused
by immediate mental associations chaos
as being wholly negative
we forget that chaos can be good such as
the chaotic exodus
of the jewish mass leaving egypt all
right um
sorry i don't totally understand your
question uh
maybe i can say it this way i would
the idea that chaos so the idea that
chaos is
negative negative in the sense not in
the sense of immoral negative in the
sense as
uh let's say non-being or not
or not or not declaration
chaos is a question chaos is
chaos is what is it right it's asking
what is this
and so it's a it's a it's a it's asking
for an answer so
so chaos asks the light
to sh to reveal it's or to to contain it
or to reveal it okay
so in that sense that's also the
relationship between
the masculine and feminine aspects of uh
of
let's say chaos and order or chaos and
name or something like that
um and and so in that sense that's the
best way to understand that now
there is definitely this relationship of
so you can understand it like you can
kind of understand it as
these principalities that have fallen so
they're below so you can have a like you
have a mac
microcosm and then you also have our
world which is smaller let's say
and then you also have uh
you also have these parasites and things
at the bottom but some of the predators
are not
negative they're not below they're above
the predators are often above
that's if you don't you need to
understand that in order to understand
uh symbolism like uh
let's say predatorial birds or
predatorial lion
the lion is seen as like above and so is
the bird and
and these this is more like the
predatorial aspect of heaven and there
is a
predatorial aspect of heaven in the
sense that heaven picks things up and
and lifts them up i've talked about this
before um and so i think that
yeah so i think that i'm struggling with
like the categories that you're
you're you're you're trying to fit into
this and and so i hope that my
my rambling was helpful to to for you to
understand that
um all right and so luca askovic
asks hello jonathan how does one stop
fearing
demons this is related to our talk
it's okay if you don't remember the
question still stands
um usually whenever i have an anxiety i
face it head-on but
in this case i don't want to call for
something that i cannot
fight or assimilate yeah i don't call
don't call up demons and don't
the the church fathers say we we we
shouldn't face demons directly at least
unless we know exactly what we're doing
and we know exactly how to
how to uh deal with them the idea is not
so much to
it's not just to face the demon that's
that's a dangerous thing one of the ways
to
deal with demons is to attach yourself
to something higher
rather than just facing the demon or if
you at least if you're going to face the
demon you need to make sure you're
attached to something
higher or else that demon is going to
going to kill you or
or it's going to go away and then it's
going to come back with its friends and
it's going to come
devour you right and so it's not you
know it's that's one of the reasons why
and i suffer from this as well like
everybody suffers from this but that's
why for example
the the church fathers always say that
during lent it's not
enough to just fast if you fast and you
don't pray
then you're getting trouble like it's
you're going to be in serious trouble
because if you just try to
hold off the passions but you don't
attach yourself to something above
then it's those passions are going to
come back and loop and
are gonna you're gonna swipe your feet
from under you um
so i think that that's the best way is
to attach yourself to something above
prayer um you know counsel from from
a priest a pastor depending on what your
tradition is
um you know those are the things or even
if you're a child like you know your
parents asking
from asking help from some someone who
has some authority over you
is also a way to to help you to fight
your demons
um bearing in mind so is it or asked
bearing in mind the symbolism of six and
six six six can you speak on this
six feet apart coping policy and burying
someone six feet under
it was really hilarious uh that someone
posted um
at the early part of kobe there was like
a red cross poster
and it showed how you're supposed to be
apart from everybody
and so it showed like someone and then
and then it had people in different
directions from them and it was like six
six
six and so it was pretty funny uh it has
to do with that with the distance of man
and six six feet is like let's say the
ideal
distance of a of a man i think and so i
think that that's
that's one of the reasons why we bury
people 16 under you can imagine like
a man's especially northerners
especially kind of
european types like a man standing and
then you bury
the person at the feet of what that
would be like if you dug a
hole and you have a prison standing from
head to toe then you put that you put
the person at the feet
of that of that standing man and i think
that the kind of intuition of wanting
people to stand six feet apart
has to do with this idea that it's the
distance of a person it's like
you need to have between you and another
person the distance of someone
it seems like that's kind of a an easy
intuitive way to go about
talking about distance because obviously
this actual six feet is clearly
arbitrary it's not
i don't see how how that can be like a
scientific thing
um
all right okay so look so there's a
question by someone named heather
heather i'm not gonna read your question
it's too long you guys can't
you can't write like three paragraphs
and and and uh
so maybe next time try to just kind of
condense your question
because it's just too much all right
samuel asks
um hi jonathan please don't
think i'm trying to get you in trouble
for this
oh man but this is something i'm
struggling with and hope you can help do
you think you can catch coronavirus from
taking communion thanks and sorry
so i would say just like my other
questions i need to
i need you to submit to your authorities
in terms of what their how they're
dealing with uh coveted and that's what
you need to do you need to submit your
authorities but
i would say that my first
reaction gut reaction to to to that
question is
no you can't get coronavirus from taking
communion
um because
the question the question i i i'm
laughing because it's like you
you'd never get corona you don't get
coronavirus from taking communion
you get coronavirus from get it from
being in contact with coronavirus
so so interpret that as you will
all right so white year two says my
family goes to a non-denominational
church
and like most reformed churches there's
a heavy emphasis on mission and
evangelism both local international
how does orthodox church read the great
commission in matthew 28 thank you
go therefore make disciples of all
nations baptizing them in the name of
the father son of the holy spirit
teaching them to observe all
i have commanded you and behold i am
with you always to the end of the age
so i mean the orthodox have always been
uh
have had always been very active in
terms of
the mission field that is you know if
you look at the movement
from constantinople you know
out into russia bulgaria
all the the you know all of the balkans
were basically evangelized by the
orthodox over the centuries
and um and so yeah it's definitely part
of
part of the orthodox ethos i think that
i would say that the orthodox probably
put a large emphasis on
you know make them disciples not just
save them
not just you know because there's
something about the kind of mass
the mass mission
work that goes out and tells people just
to believe in jesus and they'll be saved
you know that that obviously orthodoxy
is a slower process because
it there's a whole ethos which comes
with it there's a whole training
you know the fact that for example
catechumen usually you are a catechumen
for at least a year before you're
you're baptized before you enter into
the communion and so it's like it's not
a
it's not an easy thing becoming orthodox
is not easy
and so because of that it's also a
slower process
and orthodoxy also tends to not be
subversive
in the way that it converts people which
is something that
some people will struggle to understand
but
orthodoxy tends to
move through through let's say
the conversion of princes you know uh
and so this is something that
protestants will really struggle to
understand
but there's an idea that that there's
something about
a respect of the hierarchy so so
orthodoxy is not meant to come and
subvert the political order within a
state
it rather comes and tries to bring
christ into
a fulfillment of the of the state itself
and so orthodoxy doesn't
bring revolutions in in countries or in
peoples
it brings about usually the conversion
of the king or the prince and you see it
in so many examples in how orthodoxy
spreads from
from constantine to uh to to different
parts of the world uh and so then it
ends up being like a
a fulfillment of the the very nature of
that
those people and it doesn't become a a
uh
doesn't come like a weird parasite in
the culture so that's how i see it at
least when i look at the way orthodoxy
spread that's what i see
and it's a it's very weird and but it's
different today for sure because look at
me
i converted to orthodoxy in the in a
kind of weird post-catholic world so
you know it's not a universal thing
um all right okay
so eddie t asks hello jonathan i've got
a question about the nature
of the devil's motive for rebelling
against god
is the devil a usurper who aspires to
take god's place on the heavenly throne
or
is he more like a modern-day anarchist
who seeks to abolish hierarchies all
together no
for sure uh well first of all anarchists
are not anarchists they're never really
anarchists
especially violent anarchists they're
little tyrants they they
they say anarchy but what they really
mean is if
you know kind of like how jordan
peterson phrased it if i was in charge
you know if i
i will destroy this but if my ideas if
my
you know vision was in charge then it
would everything would go smoothly
um and so the
the satan is prideful he wants he
believed that it stops at him like he
believes that he's equal to god
and that's the origin of all sins and
it's the origin of
all of all evil which is to think that
reality stops at you to think
you contain everything and that's when
you you
you discount your relationship to the
infinite and you want to contain
everything
then that's when things start to break
apart and that's the nature of rebellion
all right and so bleeding mermaid whoa
asks
with halloween approaching it all i
thought i'd ask you about the symbolism
of ghosts
and our modern idea of paranormal
activity
we know demons exist but i'm curious as
to why people claim to see ghosts of
dead human beings who are haunting them
if this is a modern idea or if it has
roots and premodernity
why do we see dead people
well we see dead people because we
remember them that is dead people don't
stop to exist
when we when they die
i think the best way to understand
ghosts or
hauntings is has to do with a
kind of residue it has to do with a
residue of a person
and so it's not i don't think that when
people see ghosts
or if they encounter these types of
events that what they're encountering
is the actual dead person it's
it's the actual dead person in the way
that i encounter
residues of people if i you know i can
i've talked about this before like if i
move it to somebody's house
and they haven't um removed the
paintings and they've left everything
the way it is then i'm encountering
residues of these people and so this you
can imagine it as physical residues of
the person right so traces of the person
that live there but you can also imagine
something like psychic residue of the
person that is
you know you know and because also
places are are living they're not there
isn't
a total disconnect with the idea that
people live somewhere and how their
their their psyche influenced that space
uh it's probably the best way i can
explain it but
you know i'm not surprised that this
happens like you know it's not
someone says that the place is haunted
it's not i don't think they're making it
up there's that there's phenomena that
is going on there which is
which is probably manifesting a
a conjunction between the people who are
encountering those phenomena like it's
it's probably not just the ghosts the
ghosts
are whatever is influencing the space
is probably sensitive to the person that
person too like
there needs to be hook in that person
for the ghost to really manifest
themselves
at least that's what i what i think and
so it's like why are we talking about
this stuff
man i guess it's halloween um
um and so yeah that's good as that's
gonna get
all right so si siretta asks hey
jonathan
to carry the theme of this halloween
spooktacular
what um all right so monsters
historically
they were threatening and external to
human civilization over time they became
more human more internal more harmless
today monsters
are portrayed as parents and lovers and
friends entirely benevolent and entirely
internal yeah
violent society places monsters outside
but that is not enough if the monsters
are not also dangerous your kid will go
make friends with one and ride it into
your home
is there a way to refrank monsters
without catastrophe
i mean i think i think that it's
inevitable you know i think that
for sure right now there's a we there's
an extreme because we are
so obsessed with marginal and so because
we're so
obsessed with equality we end up
actually
you know destroy or we end up actually
affecting the very
struggle of the very structure of how
monsters appear to us you know sesame
street i've talked about this in several
talks
you can check out my my uh talks on the
pentecost of the zombie apocalypse which
will be featured with by two more v's on
on halloween
you know but the monster will always
return the monster will always return
even if you try to suppress it
and then you you just have to pay
attention you just have to pay attention
to the way that um
to the way that people who love monsters
speak and
you'll catch them you'll catch them
talking about monsters you'll catch them
talking about
the dangerous stranger uh one way or the
other
you know the those that are not like us
whether it and if it's a super
like uh if it's like a super lefty
uh extremely open person they they're
scared of you know right-wing people
yeah you know the image of
the of the okay here's a here's a
left-wing monster if you want one and
it's a very common one
the inbred hick from the bayou
right now that's a left-wing monster
that's like a
that's the monster of people who are
open to everything
and the inbred hick is exactly a monster
in the sense that
the the idea of the inbred person who
becomes
a kind of monster because the levels of
causality which are normal between
couples and a man and a woman and a
society are broken
then that is but it's a it's like a
left-wing monster because instead of
it's like it's a too close how can i say
this it's
they see it's a right-wing disease to be
inbred would be like a right-wing
disease it's like
you're keeping things too close you're
holding things too tight you're not
you're not willing to go out of outside
of the of the tribe enough and so
that's what creates the inbred hick
monster but it's still a monster because
it's still
a breakdown in causality you know there
are breakdowns in causality that are
that are let's say relationships with
things that are too far
you know the idea of the foreign woman
that you find in scripture the idea of
the
the the woman whose feet go down to
death that
that solomon talks about in the proverbs
you know this idea
of of uh of demon of angels having
relationships with with
fallen men like this too far but there's
also it too close
you know and that's why there are all
these these uh i talked about the
sins of purity that you find in
scripture there's a few places where you
find these sins of purity
and incest seems to be to be one but it
also breaks down the
the normal causality between
the opposites right and so
always remember that that that there are
different kinds
monsters will always return you cannot
avoid them
all right okay so here we go so timothy
asks
once you told us a riddle about a
dialogue in your brother's book you guys
will not leave me alone with that
alright so in the dialogue esau
asked jacob to journey together but
jacob replies that he will travel at the
place of the flock until both of them
meet in seir
why did your brother put this passage in
his book we found some comments from
matthew that relates
jacob with the slow pace of god making
the foundation stone
and esau with the accelerated pace of
man trying to emulate god's work with
bricks
did they meet at seer when jesus unites
jacob and esau in himself
or did they meet at the end of times uh
lego you've given me a way to answer it
that i that i that i can
uh which is so yes they both
meet when jesus unites jacob and esau
and himself and in the seed form
but then they also meet in the end
when they they and this is the mystery
if you want to understand it it's the
mystery that
saint paul refers to when he talks about
the branches that is cut from the tree
you know and then
it's cast into the fire and then the
other branch which is which is put back
into onto the onto the tree and so
and so yeah that's that's as much as i'm
going to give you guys
you can figure it out you know it's not
it's not that hard you can figure it out
all right so esau is edom always
remember that esau
is is uh is is
and he's related to cain as well right
so issa is related to kane
in the sense that he's the brother that
tries to kill his brother
and uh yeah
all right okay here we go roxanne asked
thank you for your generous work here's
a fairy tale question the grimm brothers
story the golden bird parallels
the story of prince avon and the grey
wolf however the prince's
animal ally is a fox once the prince has
achieved his quest the fox implores the
prince to kill him
and cut off his head and pause as far as
the prince refuses but finally complies
the fox is transformed and revealed to
be the brother of the princess from the
golden castle
happiness ensues personal tastes aside
do you see this as a distortion or a
valid symbolic variation on the story
i've never heard of this story and so
i'd have to think
about it really um
i'd have to think about it because does
i don't i wouldn't think it's a
distortion
you know fairy tales have all kinds of
different versions they're never
they're never uniform in there they
appear to us uniform because we read
them in books but
in kind of traditional world they always
have tropes and variations on how they
manifest themselves and so
i'd have to think about it about and i'd
have to read it too to unders to see
if the brother of the princess there's a
relationship
in other places in that story you know
what's his relationship to the princess
what's his relationship to the to the
main character
so sorry i can't answer anymore but i
don't know the story well enough
um so hi jonathan your video
on the parable of the sower has been
really helpful in understanding the
depth
of this symbolic pattern and how it
manifests in my life
all of matthew 12 seems to be preparing
for the parable of the sower what is the
symbolic significance of king david
eating the bread of the presence from
the temple
how might this relate to the role of
blasphemy and even the return of an
unclean spirit how does
how do we till the right ground for the
red seed
so the significance of king david eating
the bread
of the presents from the table is is
super important
it's super important because
in a way it's an imperfect it's an
imperfect
version of what christ is going to do
that is i've talked about this before
you're right that
it does have to do with the role i
wouldn't use the word blasphemy but
it does have to do with the role of
bringing
the improper and healing the improper
and so the messiah
is able messiah connects all the levels
of the hierarchy together
this is something that i've tried to
kind of explain that the messiah
christ doesn't isn't only at the top of
the mountain but he links
all the hierarchy together and that
explains a lot of the strangeness of his
story
if you see it that way then all of a
sudden a lot of things seem to make
sense
and there are a lot of things that
christ
does which can seem like
like transgressions almost but if you
understand it that he's doing this
then you can see uh then you can see
that
he he's manifesting this union and so
you know the idea that king david
you know is given the bread of heaven
and the fact that he kind of does he
does something which is considered
sacrilegious
it has to do with some of the some of
the things that christ does like the
idea of
offering his body and blood to be eaten
you know and
the idea of joining the extremes
together in in this kind of holiness
and then this kind of sacrilege which
appears in the form of the cross right
the form of the cross
is the idea of the union
of the highest and the lowest together
in one
image and so and i think that that's
what happens there's many
versions of that in scripture one of the
stranger ones is of course
you know saw samson who takes the door
of the city and brings it to the top of
the hill
it's like you know you take the door of
the outside and then you you carry it up
the hill
when you read it in the story it just
sounds so odd like why would he do that
but do you understand that that's one of
the things samson
samson is trying to do he's trying to
kind of join
all the all the levels together the
lowest and the highest together
the first and the last beginning and the
end right that's one of the things he's
trying to do
um but he's doing it kind of in an
imperfect and and uh
and mismatched way whereas christ has
really revealed the perfection of the
symbolism
um
um all right
let me just check something
um all right so
is kanye west the catacomb of so
tan musan moosman asks is kanye west the
catacomb
of second thessalonians will he the
catacomb and the great schism
do you see our political climate
pointing to the return of the king so
i'm not sure i understand your reference
because maybe i don't know
what that is what is this
so let me just check this controlled one
of those all right i don't know enough
about
the concepts that you're that you're
trying to get me to talk about so i'm
not sure
what it is you mean um but i can answer
your your second
question um do you see our political
climate pointing to the return of the
king
i think that yes
uh i i think it it does but i think
i think that doesn't mean it's gonna
happen
it can get a lot worse it can get a lot
worse
before it gets better so so
yeah so don't keep your hopes up i mean
i think that it inevitably it has to at
some point
point to that but uh you know
and it can also be a negative thing it
doesn't mean it's going to be positive
because i think
the image of antichrist is obviously an
image of a kind of kingly figure
which who is trying to be everything and
so
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so it's not
necessarily going to be good but it can
be it can be
there could be a kind of uh wake up and
a return to order and a return to proper
what kind of proper hierarchy you could
say that's that that could that could
happen
right or maybe only in the eschaton
maybe
okay so here we go so i'm now done with
the symbolic world i think
and i'm gonna move into subscribe star
okay so nicola asks
i honestly don't know if this is a good
idea but could you call in some favors
to get yourself
an interview with joe rogan i don't
think i
have access to joe rogan i don't think
that
i don't think that i i have enough clout
in the
in the in the world it to be
invited on jerogan you know whatever who
knows it might happen one day
i'd be happy to talk to joe rogan i
think that he is a good listener and
he's a
and he's a smart guy and if if he gives
people room to speak and so it could
really be
he could really be a vessel to kind of
talk about symbolism to a very very
large audience
but you know he he's he's the biggest
podcaster in the world and i and because
my work is not
very political there there would have to
be like a major controversy around me
for him to
invite me on his podcast all right
so david asks when explaining the
parable of the sower christ talks about
isaiah
through isaiah about forgiving them
their sins if only they would just turn
and understand with their hearts
as a denizen of the edge of the world
for over 10 years my physical spiritual
and life in general
has fallen apart completely well i'm
sorry to hear this david i wanted to ask
you what is meant by
understand with their hearts does this
refer to the flash of insight and
meaning
to doing various good deeds to does it
refer to repentance
and get your life together does it refer
to becoming a monk and spiritual
purification i'm seeped in sin
please help me to understand good sir
and so the notion of the heart is really
just the notion of the center of your
being
and so the idea of
turning and understanding with your
heart
has to do with first of all turning in
the sense of being receptive
to turn you have to stop going in the
direction you're going
and so you have to that's one of the
aspects of repentance repentance
means that you're going in a direction
and then you turn
right you turn around and then when you
turn then
you also have to be your heart has to be
available
the center of your being has to be
available to receive
the the new seed you would say and so
if you understand things with your heart
and with the center of your being
then they will transform you and they
will become
they will kind of have repercussions on
the the the rest of your life but the
thing is is that you can't
it's hard to provoke that it's hard for
you to
provoke understanding things with your
heart
and the best way to
do it is to repent like to break down
your
and it's not it's not just a it's not
just like a moral
thing that that you hear all the time it
really is a structural
thing which is that if you want to have
light
you have to break down the the existing
patterns and so
if you repent from your sins
and you do it sincerely and you do it
you know every time that you sin and you
you make a habit of repentance
then you you're breaking down the kind
of
disorder let's say the parasitical
patterns that are in your life and you
open yourself up to then understanding
christ with your heart or receiving
christ in your heart to use a kind of
evangelical
way of talking about it into and then
and then that will take hold in your
center
and it will start to ripple out but
like i said because it's hard to do that
it's hard for you to will that
into being it's it's it's more
the only way to really do it is through
repentance is by
starting by breaking down the current
patterns
you know um and that's what baptism does
as well baptism is a breakdown of the
kind of dysfunctional patterns that are
there at the time
all right so xrd ask hi jonathan i'm
really liking your videos on
postmodernism's viral nature
i shared the latest with my friend and
you wondered if you've commented on the
whole
cuties the netflix movie debacle
now it's obvious why ideal ideologies
target children for indoctrination but
something about post-modernism hostility
towards childhood stands out to me in
particular what are your thoughts
on that yeah i haven't talked about that
um but mostly because i i try to avoid
it try to avoid clickbait controversy in
general
like i'll talk about things that are
there in politics but i try to avoid
that
kind of heated stuff that really pops up
you know
but um
if you want to understand let's say
you know the world always manifests
itself in extremes and so
you know i was thinking about making a
video on this because but i maybe do it
on bit shoot or something because on
on youtube like just answering your
question will probably
bring me give me trouble with youtube
but
the two extremes of culture manifest
themselves in the way that they
act and then also in the way that they
interpret what the other person is
acting and so
let's say the desire to
sexualize children is first of all a
desire to bring
the passion down at the
at as low as as close as possible to the
origin
okay because one of the aspects of the
of the modern
of the modern world let's say the more
the kind of the more chaotic
part of the modern world the more kind
of open and degenerate part of the
modern world is
to want to reduce everything to desire
right to want to reduce everything to
our passions our passions are the only
things that are true
and so it's inevitable that they want
not only desire
themselves those that are end up
desiring those that are
younger they also want to they want to
project desire
into as close to the origin as possible
because that's what they are
like that's what they that's their being
and so yeah and uh
and so it's just it's just gonna happen
and it happens
almost in a in an unconscious way
because if you look at the way that
it's the movie was was at least framed
as being anti
against the the the sexualization of
children but then it ends up doing it
anyways
and so it just it's like a weird
unconscious thing that
that people engage in and end up kind of
manifesting nonetheless so at least
that's how i
understand that but one day i'll make a
video about
let's say
the other aspect of that is is kind of
racism and the way people view each
other like it's
pedophiles versus racist something like
that uh
and so anyways we can talk about that
but this is this is probably
this is gonna get me in trouble all
right okay here we go so dorothy kkk
says
uh hi jonathan i recently read the
chapter about dreams in your brother's
book i think that chapter was the
soundest
thing i read on the topic but i'm
struggling to relate those dream
interpretations
with the outside world i get the idea
that not having enough heaven would mean
a lack of heavenly guidance that our
passions are taking over or something
like that but what does it mean to not
have enough body
can you give some examples or am i
looking at this the wrong way
uh well i've given a few examples of not
having enough body
uh utopia utopia is the best example
of not having a body or not being
capable
of manifesting in body and so
and so you you have something which is
too high
and doesn't just can't land in the world
can't really find
a body you know
and so you imagine uh people who
have let's say extreme conspiracy
theorists also
let's say they they they don't have
enough body
and so they have these ideas about the
world and they have an idea about the
way that the world works
and they they end up kind of floating in
these ideas
and then they they they try to they
connect things
below but they don't totally connect and
so they're actually not really connected
but they really want to see them as
being connected and so
you know anything any idea that doesn't
have enough
instantiation in the world is something
that doesn't have enough body
right let's say a false scientific uh a
false scientific theory
will end up not having enough body in
order to be real it'll
it'll just kind of float up into the air
and won't
and won't land um so those are a few
examples
um and i mean like an example in your
life because i see you're trying to
relate it to your life is
is of course the idea of having ideals
that are too high right
so it's like okay so i'm gonna stop
smoking tomorrow right
you've heard that kind of stuff i'm
going to i'm going to
start exercising next week and i'm going
to do it every day
and i'm going to do it for an hour a day
and then
nothing happens right those are not
having enough body those are having
ideas that don't land and don't don't
manifest themselves
and you meet people like that who have
projects who always have wild huge
projects
you know someone who wants to be a
writer you know
this is a great example someone who's
like oh i want to write novels like i
want to write novels
then you ask them like uh so have you
you know have you written some short
stories have you written a few smaller
texts and maybe you've tried to publish
have you
have you worked on the let's say
uh just the outline of your novel
it's like no but i want to write great
novels like i want i only i want to be a
great author i want to be the best
author
but they're not willing to put in the
like little work that you need to do to
kind of get there
and so they just end up being these
lofty dreams that never land
and never never make never uh become
anything
everybody has both met people like that
and also
have had those in their life themselves
so
okay so here we go on to uh patreon
so i was really tired when i started
this but i'm i'm feeling pretty
energized also because a lot of these
questions
are you're leading you guys are leading
me into like difficult corners that i
need to get out of
all right okay so g garcia asked do you
think it's possible to fully escape the
materials world view
if you were born in it or is it more
responsibility to raise inculcate the
next generation with symbolic lens so
they don't have the same problems as us
sometimes it feels like instead of
viewing the world under a microscope i'm
now looking at symbols under a
microscope
hope that makes sense thank you yeah i
mean it makes sense i understand what
you're saying
you know this is of course one of the
dangers
of what i'm doing and i mentioned this
in a few
videos a few talks before is that
there's a danger in explaining symbolism
it's almost like a last-ditch
medicine right it's like okay the world
is going to hell
everything's falling apart we have to
explain the symbolism
because it's explaining symbolism and
living symbolism is not the same right
let's say manifesting symbolic patterns
and living in them
is not the same as understanding them
and it's not the same as explaining them
but you hope that it's going to be at
least a ladder because
it's better than being in the crazy
upside down symbolism
so at least it gives you tool to first
off break out of the upside down
symbolism
and then hopefully start to climb the
ladder so that you can integrate some of
these symbolic things
but i agree that it's difficult and i
don't know if it's fully possible
um yeah all i can say is by the grace of
god and just
one little thing at a time you know one
little integration at a time
so benjamin kinkade asks
hi jonathan there are a lot of troubling
things going on in the upside down world
can you talk about what gives you the
most hope how are you seeing this acted
out in the world and what stories
portray this in scripture
i mean it's you know what gives me the
most hope right now i'll tell you guys
it's you guys it's you guys that give me
the most hope
and uh you know the
you guys know that there's a facebook
with a symbolic world facebook group
where there's really active and lively
discussion
and out of that has been coming articles
on the symbolic world blog
just wonderful articles great high
quality articles
and you know it's not like
the blog right now has a huge has a huge
readership but what it does and what it
is it's like a training ground it feels
like
i can i'm looking out now in the world
and i'm seeing these little seedlings
like i'm seeing these little
trees that you know ten years ago even
six years ago
i there was nothing i've met here and i
felt like we were the only people in the
world that really thought this way it
really
was able we're able to perceive the
symbolic patterns and so
all of a sudden i look out and i see it
and i see it
like and it comes back to me in weird
ways like it comes back to me in
like secondary ways where uh you know
i'll read an article and it's obviously
not somebody who follows me but in that
article i'll see that there are things
that
five years ago i never could have seen a
way of seeing the world
way of explaining which seems to be kind
of permeating
kind of and i think that i'm
participating it matches participating
it other people are but it's like i can
see
it growing and so i feel like this is it
this is the hope for the future
right that we're the hope for the future
that
we i mean we in the sense that people
who are able to discern these patterns
and will hopefully try to integrate them
in new stories
and and also kind of re-enliven the old
stories
in a way that can help us reconnect with
our roots and so
and ultimately of course we connect us
to god to the extent that that's
that that you know that that's part of
it of course it's not just a
question of mental mental games and
mental understanding but
the understanding is also part of it too
so that's what gives me hope
right now i'll be honest with you
because it's not a lot
much else giving me hope okay so elise
spinola
so hi jonathan in genesis 27
isaac already blind blesses jacob
instead of esau
who was the firstborn and in genesis 48
the same situation occurs in which jacob
also blind blesses ephraim instead of
manasseh
who was the firstborn what does that
mean now this is a really interesting
interesting story because i think that
there
and i've talked about this with material
it's like there are like two
interpretations of that story and in a
way
they're they're opposite
stories the opposite interpretations
which is really fascinating
because so you can you you imagine that
so jacob okay so isaac is
tricked right and he blesses
esau right he blesses jacob instead of
esau so he's tricked into doing that so
it's a trick so so jacob flips the world
kind of flips the the world upside down
and like a trickster takes
the kind of takes the gold you know like
jack
uh jack and the beanstalk takes the gold
from the the giant right
so he's like jacob is jack and he takes
the gold
that he's not that is not supposed to go
to him so that's what it that's what
happens now
then when jacob blesses his sons
his his grandsons i mean you can
understand it
you can understand it one as he is
perpetuating the trick
and so the idea is that he actually
crosses his hands over
and he's going to bless
he's go he ends up blessing the the
younger one instead of the older
but if you read it carefully it's not
clear there are other another way of
interpreting it
which is that he's rectifying
the trick that in fact
that joseph is presenting them upside
down as if he
joseph wants to continue the the
because joseph is also kind of weirdly
part of that right joseph is not the
oldest
it's not the oldest and so joseph wants
to perpetuate the blessing of the
youngest but then jacob
ends up actually by crossing his hands
he ends up it's like a double
flip where joseph presents him the sons
upside down
to bless in the youngest first and then
jacob
double flips crosses his hands and ends
up blessing the oldest one
and it's not clear in the text which one
it is but so it's an interesting
it's an interesting uh it's an
interesting thing so it's either that
jacob wants to perpetuate the upside
down
or it's that jacob as the kind of
trickster character
has slipped the world upside down and
now he's double flipping and he's
bringing it back uh right side up
um that's the way those are the two ways
that i interpret that
so paul jamal says hi jonathan i assume
you've read dune
what did you think of its symbolism are
there particular themes that you liked
and any that you disliked man i read z i
read dune when i was
like 14 years old and i really don't
remember enough of it
and recently i tried to reread it again
i did i tried to reread it as an audio
book and i
tapped out i just couldn't i don't know
why there was something about it i just
couldn't so
i'm sorry i just don't have a good
answer for you
um i mean i do want to read it at some
point i would i would like to a lot of
people are telling me that i should
and that there's some interesting things
going on in there
but i like i said i don't remember i
read it way too long ago and my
perceptions weren't weren't uh sharp
enough at the time for me to now
remember what what was
good about it um so sandra cutert asked
how's your family doing
yeah man yeah it's tough it's a tough
time
it's tough time for everybody but uh i
mean we still
we still hope to get into our house
that's really just been the like
the weight on our shoulders is to still
be in this rented house after
you know more than a year and uh
yeah it just we just it just it just has
to end
so that's pretty much what's going on
but in general i would say we're doing
we're doing okay i think that like we
haven't i think i mentioned that in the
last q a it's like
i haven't been back to church since
colgate started because
it was shut down then it was opened and
it was shut down again
now i think it's open i don't i'm not
even it's as if i'm not even
and so that has been bad for me at least
for my soul i need to i need to kind of
find a way to go to confession and go to
church
so that needs to happen so pray for me
for that guys but everybody is kind of
in a similar situation
unless you're in like the south
somewhere where it's totally open and
it's as if
nothing happened but at least in canada
we're all kind of going through this
um so christopher asks what is your
favorite book or story in the bible and
why
um i mean there's no competition for
that
it's definitely i mean it's the story of
christ that's that's for sure
if you're if we're going to break it
down in terms of of christ
it's definitely the story of the
resurrection or the crucifixion and the
resurrection so
i'm not i'm afraid i'm not going to
surprise you by that uh
if we talk about the old testament
though let's talk about the old use the
old testament because that's
you know it's it's kind of cheating to
say christ maybe um
i would say the story of the creation
story
that story you can't get enough of that
story
creation story i would say a hierarchy
would be like the creation story
the the exodus story uh story of noah of
jonah
so we know i just love all the stories
but for sure creation has got to be
creation fall is just the best
and then he asks if i offer clergy
discounts on my carvings i don't
actually offer
clergy discounts on my carvings i really
try to price my carvings
in a accessible way and so
it is possible to get a carving for me
for like three hundred dollars
and uh it's also possible to get it
carving for me for like ten thousand
dollars and so what i try to do is i
i really try to scale my prices enough
so that if someone doesn't have the
means
to get a bigger carving they can at
least get a small a small carving if
they just save up a little bit
so that's the way i do it and i try to
have my prices uh
affordable that some icons are kind of
affordable for everybody
so yeah all right so arie fisher
asks greetings jonathan of quebec in a
fairly recent interview we did
on anagogi on a go-gay podcast you got
into the issue of universalism versus
commitment to a single traditional path
i think a lot of what you said hinged on
one of your initial statements which is
that you have to be on a path
a path meaning a traditional one all
right
uh so you say that i've been attracted
to christianity
seeing how much it affords people in
their lives but in attempting to move
into it myself i've run up against the
wall that at some point
you have to actually say and believe
that this religion is the truth instead
of just being a pragmatic thing
um i've also you said you're westerner
then there's no denying that the
christian story is your story which
again i totally agree with
but should such that such a thing be the
deciding factor in one's choice of a
path
um if someone in their heart of hearts
really felt called to be a taoist
but was a westerner could you say it
would be better for them to distrust
their heart
and become a christian or follow it and
become a taoist
i mean
i think it's i think it's very it's very
difficult
for a westerner to be a taoist difficult
nearly
impossible especially a taoist of all
things man some of those
taoist stuff is so weird like
they are nearly impossible for us to
understand like all these weird
practices and weird fasting and like
weird
weird like kind of proto-medical things
that
there's a lot of it's very difficult to
be
something like a taoist uh so i don't
know how to answer your
question in the sense that i do believe
that
i do believe that
in all the legitimate traditions or all
the legitimate religions i believe that
there
are glimmers of truth that there are
things in there that are really pointing
and that are really helpful to people
and pointing higher and that are kind of
a manifestation of this pattern of
reality
and i and i do think that i i i don't
tend to
to have this like christians have it and
everybody else is is horrible i
just can't think that way it's just
impossible because i just because
christianity is the pattern of
because i believe the pattern that i see
in christ is the pattern of everything
then
then it has to kind of be there
everywhere somehow at least to
a certain extent and so that's how i
think but i i do do
think that christ offers the capstone
offers the the the integration of the
pattern in a way that
is not seen in any other uh religion and
so
it's difficult for me to answer your
question in the way
maybe you want me to answer it um
i mean i think that yeah
that's as much as i can say uh all right
so tanner mathis asked what is the
symbolism between newly wedded couples
going on trips for their honeymoon
is there something to the idea of a new
husband and wife leaning time away from
the normal social structure to form
their own bond without interference
from their past lives yes i think that's
what it is i think
uh i think that it's it's also
probably very much related to fertility
it's
it's probably related to the idea of a
if you
if you go on a honeymoon and if you take
an entire month like an
entire month which is also an entire
menstrual cycle then
you are let's say starting the idea
would probably at least an
old in the old time it probably would
have been that the person should become
pregnant
during that first month like that's
probably what
in a traditional world would have been
understood is that if you take
so it's like you take a full month
together in order to
start your family and as you said in
order to
restart the pattern of the family in a
in a
in its own with its own pattern but that
probably definitely included having a
becoming pregnant in the first month
ideally although nobody nobody would
most very few people would think of it
that way today
anyways who can take a full month
anyways like people don't take full
month honeymoons anymore at least i
don't i never heard anybody do that
so charlie longoria asks hello jonathan
when do the role of urban legends
folktales play in symbolic world view
how are they similar different from
fairy tales i always loved reading
stories that must not die as a kid we
have an urban legend in my town called
devil at the disco where a young girl
sneaks out during holy week
and dances with a handsome stranger only
to realize he's the devil
are they close to the mexican order so
we have a lot of these kinds of tales
told
for generations popular story is la
llorona and all of our grandmothers have
heard of her
haha um and so yeah the idea of that
so i would say that they're very they're
similar in the sense that
fairy tales are probably
fairy tales are more stable and they're
also longer they tend to be more
kind of cosmic in their their scope they
tend to have a more microcosmic thing
whereas these kind of small legends or
these uh these little urban legends or
small folktales they tend to be
smaller in terms of their repercussions
but for example the devil at the disco
story
is is a is a universal story you know
the idea of a young girl that
that uh dances with the devil uh we have
it in quebec we have the same
legend we have the the story of the the
woman who dances
uh with the devil and i think there's
probably there in almost every culture
there are different versions of it
though which is interesting
for example one of the versions that
exists in quebec of the woman dancing
with the devil
is that she dances him
out like she out dances the devil she
dances him through hell and then out of
hell
and the devil can't take anymore and
he's the one who gives up
so that's an interesting little tidbit
there all right so
aj daltorio asks hello good sir hope
you're doing well
i've been attending orthodox services
for a year now
i grew up so you also grew up protestant
if i could ask you something in
protestantism as you know so much of the
service is off the cuff
or from the heart you could say i'm not
so used to this way of doing things that
reading from the liturgy can seem dull
i'm not saying the problem is the way
orthodox do things because the problem
is certainly with me
i'm used to fast food and now being
forced to eat vegetables yeah i
understand that
anyways i was wondering if you were able
to struggle with that and if you did did
it get easier
i would say yes i did struggle with that
and i think
uh like my kids definitely struggle with
that 100 percent
even my wife struggles with that kind of
stuff um
i think it's normal because we like you
said we're used to
this more kind of personal informal way
of doing things
uh the key i think is to
is to to kind of tame the liturgy i
would say
that is to get to know it and once if
you get to know it and it becomes
familiar to you then it won't it first
of all it won't be as
dull and second of all it it will be
more like
a um you'll know
where you are and so you'll feel like
you're you're you're
on a path like you're in you're in
something that you that you know what's
going on and that can help so
understanding
the different sections like the two main
sections of the liturgy and then
understanding
why the liturgy is built the way it is
and you know what it's leading up to
um can kind of help you to
to participate more actively and uh and
so that you're also not
just going rogue but you you engage
personally as you're going through the
the liturgy
um all right so keenan wang
asks i hear you talk about the function
of christ in the hierarchy what do you
see as the function of the holy spirit
um well i mean first of all
yeah i so christ
and let's not go into that okay so the
holy spirit
is so you can understand
the the in the role of manifestation you
could say
the holy spirit is that which kind of
fills or
you can imagine it as the breath that is
under the word and so it has to do with
this kind of
has to do with this kind of filling and
opening and
and uh it can also be represented as
fire as this kind of
spreading out of the presence of god
into
into something and so it has to do with
this
so the holy spirit officially in the
story of pentecost so you can see how
the holy spirit
is kind of coming down and going to the
going all the way to the end right so
manifesting the different languages
with the tongue of fire right so so this
idea of speaking fire
that so that it splits into all these
different aspects um
and so that's why i also like that so
the spirit
comes down upon the waters comes down
upon man god blows his spirit into the
dust
and then it kind of saturates the dust
and brings it together
that's the best way that at least i can
understand that
so what is the symbolism of the gospel
and why did the angels long to look into
it the gospel
okay it was revealed to them that they
were serving not themselves but you
and the things that have now been
announced to you
through those who preached the good news
to you by the holy spirit sent from
heaven
things into which angels long to look
into
well it's the incarnation that's what i
think that the angels
the angels wish to look onto the
incarnation that is
that this is the mystery let's say of
the incarnation it's the mystery of also
man
which is that by
we are lower than the angels but the
ultimate mystery is that by
being filled as we are filled by the
spirit and as where we are
we manifest let's say the incarnational
principle in christ
sorry guys um then
we end up being more than the angels
that we end up actually containing more
it's like so it's not so being above is
one thing but
filling up the hierarchy is another so
we have bodies and so
the the idea of this the incarnational
principle is that which
the angels look down upon and wish right
and that's why they
that's why they had intercourse with
women because they saw the flesh and
they
kind of desired the flesh there's
something about that which is above
which kind of
peers into that which is below and
desires it or
or is it longs for it okay and uh and so
that's
one of the reasons why human beings end
up being kind of
higher ultimately higher than the angels
or more
full than the angels or something like
that
all right so how many questions are left
man all right okay here you go so walrus
king 14
asks hello jonathan with halloween
coming up soon i have a question about
inversion holidays do you find that they
can still provide value to a person
desiring to live a symbolic christian
life in our modern society
i often hear other christians say that
the celebration of such holidays is
blasphemous or demonic
or heretical without truly understanding
the historically symbolic roots of said
holidays however
i rarely hear anyone talk about their
usefulness in our present society
you feel like do you feel that the
inversion holidays lose their meaning
and purpose in a world that is
constantly inverted
is there an appropriate way to reclaim
these holidays or are they better
off lost to time i mean i agree with you
i think that
i think one of the reasons why people
put so much
like why christians end up having like a
more puritan
vision on these invergent holidays
is that the world is completely upside
down and so they
see for example that
you know so there's something real about
it which is that if you celebrate
halloween more than you celebrate
christmas
and if halloween is a bigger holiday you
know and if
halloween tries to take over christmas
then
then it's a serious problem right it's a
it's it's it's a sign of our times
and so i think that people perceive that
and their intuition isn't wrong
uh
but in the end they're always going to
be there they're not going to be able to
get rid of
the inversion of holidays you just can't
right traditional christians
uh like i saw some you know people will
bash halloween i understand but then
they still celebrate
some kind of carnival some kind of mardi
gras they'll still go to
the fair and they'll still go on the
ferris wheel and
and go on the the merry-go-round and ooh
and turn around
sitting on a bunch of weird animals
they'll still do that
it's not they can't you can't totally
avoid it
and so i think that it's better to
understand it but it's also
i think it's also good not to be a
scandal to people so and so i think that
if you
meet a christian who who doesn't
understand
the purpose of the gargoyles and doesn't
understand the purpose of the
of the upside down it's there's no
point in pushing it on them there's no
point in trying to
to make them react by talking about it
or by bringing it up you know
but i mean i think that it's useful for
us to understand these and to understand
the role of the margin and the upside
down and all of this and how
it's there in scripture it's it appears
in many places in scripture
um and so it's like these are the the
types of christian
man i can't believe i'm saying this but
it's like the type of christian that
totally doesn't understand let's say
inversion festivals
is usually the type of christian which
really doesn't like
many of the stories in the bible or
pretend like they do but they really
don't and and also
maybe don't even know them don't really
even know all the weird stories that are
in the old testament because
and there's a lot of weird stuff in the
old testament and purim
which is an inversion festival which is
based on the book of esther and was
there in the time of christ
is an inversion festival i'm sorry to
tell you it's and it's a
it's a it was there during the time of
christ so
i know what to tell you all right
so lucas fernbach asked what is the
symbolic meaning of bow
i don't know i mean in the sense
in that in the sense of the israelites
baal is the
is the foreign god right and so baal is
the
is the foreign god which asks you to
sacrifice your children to
so it's a it's a foreign god that has a
born practices
and and they you know engages in
you know where there's like kind of a
sacred prostitution and all these things
which are
which are uh kind of for the israelites
are seen
as defiling and so it has
very much something to understand about
how the foreign god brings about
beings about abhorrent practices and
defiling practices
so france schnetler asked i noticed that
on the cover of timothy wares the
orthodox church there's a striking
depiction of jesus
in a mandarin that i can't help but see
as incredibly
yeonic i might be going insane but even
the position of his head and body evokes
it yeah
uh it's made stranger by the red bolts
coming out of his hands that he vote
that invoked blood how is this to be
understood tobacco is an orthodox
christian
uh look
i don't know what to tell you bro i mean
i think that i think you have to be
careful not to see things upside down
i think that i think that understanding
the mandurala somehow as a
as a covering or as a glory in the sense
of a
in the sense of the feminine as the
glory of man
right if you uh if you see that in um
in uh i think it's in providence where
it says that the wife is the glory of
her husband
uh then there's not it's not completely
insane it's not completely insane but i
would be careful not to see things
upside down and then not to see
not to understand
not to understand like genitalia as the
root of symbolism but understand
genitalia as an examples of
the symbolic patterns right and so it's
and
yeah that's the best way to for me to
say that without getting into that too
much
um okay so why do elves have pointed
ears
chase and lindsey asked huh
i don't know i don't need to think about
that
why do elves have pointed ears and i'm
sure mets you would have a great answer
to that
i never thought about that i'll think
about it if i think if something comes
before the end of the q a i'll answer
but i don't have a quick answer for you
on that
so drew mcmahon asked the new testament
gives accounts of jesus
at birth as a child just one story and
the remainder as an adult is their
symbolism of these specific time frames
i mean i think that for sure it seems
like
christ they show the image of christ at
birth
at the beginning of adolescence and as
an adult so i think
that seems to be what's going on is that
it's really kind of
synthesizing the different trans major
transitions
in uh in human life without going into
detail
so that's that's kind of how i see it
um and the way that they do it seems to
be to
for you to see that christ was
already what he is right from the
beginning right so
right when he's born the magi come and
and
give him gifts and then when he becomes
a teenager
he you know all the wise men in the
temple listen to him
this seems to be one of the reasons it
seems to me it seems to be the reason
why
why it's done that way
all right so the wakeful asks dear
jonathan my friend suffered a crisis of
belief in faith while a young man in
protestant church
this was a problem related to many this
was related to many of the problems
with liberalism materialism and lack of
symbolism that you describe
he is beginning to feel the need for
religion again and is receptive to your
ideas however the resurrection presents
a problem to him
unlike the stories in the old testament
the resurrection requires i.e the creed
to believe in a literal event he would
most
would be most comfortable with it being
a symbolic story do you know how he
might be able to approach resurrection
i mean it is a symbolic story it's it's
happened but it's also a symbolic story
it's not
you the desire to separate those is
really
one of the big problems is that
symbolism happens like symbolism is the
way the world
manifests itself and so
the way to wait so i'm putting out we're
putting out
a a video it's going to come out
probably either tomorrow or
on monday i hope uh and it's it's based
on jp marco's article on miracles
and so i think that this requires kind
of a long answer and and i've been
working up to it
i've been avoiding it a little bit just
because i needed to kind of bring people
to a certain point
but at some point
we come to uh we come to understanding
when we understand the world
that the world manifests itself as these
emergent patterns or these
these these patterns these things which
emerge into patterns and also patterns
which come down and name
the different emergent properties right
once we kind of understand this kind of
jump
up at different levels we realize that
the world emergence is moving towards
meaning
and so the miracles
that people really struggle with instead
of
actually being the the freak things that
that don't make sense and that
are how can i say this that the freak
things which
people use to destroy religion mirror
the miracles of christ
are always there to actually crystallize
how the world works in a way that is
that is beyond
normal events and so it actually brings
reality so it's like imagine all these
levels of emergence and it kind of lifts
the world
up into into kind of a crystalline
really
shining moment where meaning shows
itself and the resurrection is the
summit of that right the resurrection
is the very
the very the very way in which
things that are broken in multiple come
together
into one and that that is the pattern of
reality that
that is how things happen and that the
the pattern has more permanence than the
body and that the body
dies but the pattern doesn't and the
pattern
ultimately has the capacity to bring
back to kind of let's say to
to find a body like to find a new body
you could say it that way
um and look i can't watch the video when
the video comes out you'll see
that it's going to be hopefully it'll
help understand
but you're right that without the
resurrection there is no christianity
and it is not sufficient to think of it
as just a
kind of metaphor like a metaphor like
someone made it up like nothing happened
like
christ didn't like there wasn't an event
behind the resurrection and somebody
at some point made it up for some reason
that's definitely not the way christians
understand it the resurrection
is something that happened uh and
it's a mysterious event like i like i've
said in many of my videos
people who think they they've got it
like they know what it is
is you be careful because christ is
doesn't isn't recognized in the
resurrection that is his resurrected
body isn't recognized by the disciples
is it at first recognized by mary
magdalene isn't recognized by the
the disciples uh on the road to emmaus
and so it means that it's not a
straightforward thing
right the resurrected body is not a
straightforward like you know
someone dead on the ground and just
stands up right
it's not straightforward it's a
mysterious body it's not this it's not
the same
kind of body than the the one that you
have now and so
maybe that can help you to see to think
that it's it's not
trying to understand it in kind of weird
materialist categories it's going to
lead you astray
because the scripture seems to to
to tell the story in a way that is not
simple and is not
easy to is not easy to contain in terms
of material categories so
that's as close as i can say
so norm grande asked why do you and i
good luck to your friend on his journey
all like as i can say you know all the
best and god bless them
norm grenade says why do you feel that
it's more accurate or appropriate to
view the primary biblical narrative
as incarnational as light that comes
down and fills up the world
from jesus versus video rather than
salvation
thank you for your work
well because because if you understand
it as
incarnation oh it also contains the the
salvational
right it contains salvation it's just
bigger because it also
the incarnational story contains even
the creation story itself
so it the creation story is an
incarnational story because it ends with
it ends with the spirit of god getting
blown into
dust and and and to a dust body and that
makes man it's an incarnational
principle let's say
uh and then it ends with the glorious
city which comes down from heaven
and so at first it's like uh at first
it's a person it's a body and then at
the end it's an entire
community or it's the communion of the
saints which are let's say
that heaven are joined together heaven
and earth and so
it's bigger than just salvation and so
there is a salvational aspect
to the story in the sense that we're
lost that we're broken that we're
sick that we're you know that we're not
complete and then
the story of making us whole making us
well making us complete you know um
but that is the hot let's say
that salvation is part of the bigger
because that's what dust is too right
the dust is fragmented it's broken it's
not together
then god brings it together and then
blows the wind into
adam and so it's already so salvation is
already
is already implied even in the creation
of man
not in a moral sense but in the sense of
of things that are broken and fragmented
are brought together into
into one
all right and so n dominus asks does
artificial intelligence have symbolic
meaning what did you mean by ai is like
a fallen angel
so i've said this a few times i guess in
my videos and people are caught
are catching up to this
so the idea is that we're making
we're making uh like a a mechanical
or a connecting a connected body we're
creating this like
electric uh network
and we are
can i say this we are submitting
ourselves to it
do you do you see that what we're doing
like do you see that we're submitting
ourselves to our creation
right so we create google we create
twitter we create facebook create these
networks uh these like
information networks and these
algorithms
and then we submit ourselves to to this
kind of robot that we created and so
that
that is part of what i mean by
a fallen angel it becomes a it becomes a
principality
and it has a body and so it's a
principality with the body
and it rules over us and so
and it's very very powerful like it's
not just like uh it's not like a little
thing
it's not it's not like that can happen
in your own life in your own little
passions it's like a cosmic
thing it's like this cosmic let's say
it's like a cosmic golem like this
cosmic
structure and then we we
look at it as if it is
superior to us and as if as if it is we
we are submitting to it and and then
it's
that's it it becomes a vehicle for a
principality becomes a body
for a principality that comes down and
and uh and that's a to me that's my best
understanding of what a fallen angel is
right
so that's that's that's as much as i can
say to that
so all right guys
all right let me see so i usually i do i
will check the youtube
see if there are some super chats last
minute
all right sorry i wasn't already ready
with this
so i hope everything in the chat is
better i know last
last time there was only brad in the
chat and
you know despite him always being the
one with the flaming sword i think he
wasn't able to swing it
to swing it enough uh so
thankfully jk was there with him this
time hopefully that was helpful
all right so let's see
all right so we've got oh we've got a
two all right okay so here we go
so ulysses k hughes asks
you once mentioned for for 10 year olds
sorry you once mentioned that dante's
divine comedy was an arc
can you expand on this definition are
there other works of literature
art or music that are also arcs um
well i think that the scripture itself
in a way is a kind of arc
the the the idea that
let's say dante's comedy because the
thing about the ark especially the arc
the arc of noah as we we tend to think
of the arc of noah as like a
pure thing but the ark of noah is not is
not really a pure thing it's more like
it contains everything
in one frame and so in the ark
is are the animals at the bottom of the
ark and then
there's the head or man at the top of
the ark and you can kind of imagine you
see it sometimes in images where the
birds are kind of above or
at the top of the very very top of the
ark um and so it's a little microcosm
and so in that sense i think that dante
was able to create a microcosm
in which people could actually live and
that's really something
like people could actually dante's
uh dante's comedy ended up
creating tropes that people
actually live in and so his images of
heaven
and purgatory and uh and hell
are are images that entered into the
consciousness of people not just in a
not just in their desire to be
entertained but in the way that they
engage with their own lives their own
sins their own values
and it stretches from the from
the cosmic so there's an aspect of his
work which is
talking about god and how god reveals
himself in the world and some of the
characters that he meets are
at that level like even he even brings
in like the old gods he even brings in
the old greek gods and
roman gods and and and they're all there
like the whole antiquity is
kind of brought into the story right
everything is brought in like that's why
what i mean it's an arc like
everything of value is brought into this
one big structure
all the old at a cosmic level so the
angels the gods the the demons all of
this is there
then at all the political level and so
all these historical figures are there
but then also at the personal level and
so he encounters all the people in his
life that he had to deal with
um at the different levels of the
hierarchy so
at every step of the hierarchy he
encounters the different levels so it's
like a
it is a amazing fractal structure um
and so that's what i mean like that's an
arc because it
it's a it's a it's an amazing microcosm
but not just like
lord of the rings of the microcosm
because you can't live in lord of the
rings
but you can live in dante's comedy like
it it's a
it's a it has it's a structure of of
of the ascent of an actual person
through
you know through this kind of
mythological structure of being so
it's pretty amazing i mean dante's
comedy is an amazing thing
okay so so curious [ __ ] for 399 says
what would be the symbolism of the
gargoyle well i i think i talked about
this quite a bit
you know if you haven't seen my videos
on it i would say watch
uh stay come come on on the 31st of uh
october with two more v's and watch the
the
the pentecost of the zombie apocalypse
talk because you'll see it there but
it has to do with the monsters on the
edge it has to do with it this image of
of monsters on the outside you know on
the on the edge of the world
and then the church as a microcosm on
the edge of the church and so they have
their apotropaic that is that it's using
death
to fight off death using monsters to
fight off monsters you know
all right and so layman theologians for
five dollars says thank you well thank
you to you
father matthew for five dollars says
what do you think about the symbolism
uh present within the movie the passion
of christ
does mel gibson get the symbolism right
i think mel gibson gets a lot of the
symbolism right man i'd really struggle
to watch that movie i really didn't
really particularly like it just because
of the
just because of like mel gibson's
obsession with like
hyper violence but i would say that in
terms of the symbolism like
the symbolic patterns that he manifests
in his movies
he seems to get really really well you
know i was
it's like for example like apocalypto is
as christian a movie as the temptation
of christ like as the passion of christ
i mean
i mean his he has mel gibson is a great
storyteller like a wonderful
storyteller and a very powerful he has a
powerful symbolic intuition
so so i mean i i still think i think
that
it's going to be interesting to see
because he's doing the harrowing of hell
which is like
supposedly he's doing the sequel to the
passion which is going to be
i can't imagine i mean it might be
amazing who knows i mean he's
he's really intuitive so um what is the
monster most relevant this halloween
oh man i have no idea
it feels like i'm not even sure is there
even going to be out like i'm not sure
mike like my daughters wants to go out
on halloween and i'm like
is there even going to be halloween that
are people actually going to be
engaging and giving candy and stuff i'm
not sure because we're people in like
corona panic so
yeah well my
my daughter like my 13 year old daughter
she she's gonna dress as a plague doctor
so there you go
maybe that's that's what we need this
halloween our
people dressing up as playing doctors
do the so theodore malone asked two
witnesses in the book of revelation
describe a pattern similar to peter
and paul what about moses and enoch yes
i
i think so i think that the idea of the
two witnesses if you understand the two
witnesses
as something similar to the idea of
the transfiguration of christ where he
has these two witnesses
uh the idea of moses and elijah
or moses and enoch you know enoch and
elijah are
are very much the same in terms of the
pattern of what they manifest
and so yes they're definitely the let's
say the right hand and the left hand
moses and peter paul and enoch
and paul who was taken up to the third
heaven right um
and so i would say yes
very much so so
15 li for 1999 usd
any thoughts on the zodiac killer i'm
afraid i have no thoughts on the zodiac
killer i just don't i don't
do i don't think i even know the story
well enough to to
to to have thought about it i'm not a
yeah
um so sorry i can't answer that okay i
mean i would have to look into the story
so
shake your rain drop five dollars hi
jonathan i lost my job this week i'm
sorry
just want to say thanks for all you do
been watching since i was 16 the idea
you present have changed my life well
thank you shaky raindrop i wish you the
best
strange time it's a strange time so i
wish you the best
in finding some opportunities for your
life
so the golden thread for five dollars
asked any thoughts on movies
normally running about two hours that an
artifact of the medium or perhaps deeper
gospels
are about two hours to read as well i
don't know i've never thought about
the two-hour thing um
yeah i'd have to think about it i mean
liturgy is usually about
two hours so i wonder if there's
something
i wonder if there's something about like
a normal cycle in the human person
like i don't know the kind of cycle of
attention or cycle of participation
i'd have to think about it i'd have to
look into that
so last one last super chat here we go
luke lemon
for usd 10 10 when people say
the eyes the window to the soul is
disconnected to the wheel symbol we see
across different religions
including your symbolic world logo eyes
and wheels have a similar pattern
um
i mean i don't think so i don't i don't
think it has
necessarily to do with the wheel i mean
it can have something to do with the
wheel in the sense of
understanding the wheel as a center
with with spokes um and so the
let's say you can understand the the
center of the wheel
the the axis of the wheel or the the hub
of the wheel as being
the as being the the
the pupil right as being the hole that
the light goes through
um and so in that sense i think you can
understand it that way so if you
understand the wheel
as as this solid thing of manifestation
and in the middle especially when you
see
like in you see uh versions of the wheel
like in
in some eastern traditions where there's
a it's like it's
empty in the middle so it's like a
circle empty circle in the middle and
then
there's the spokes so it's this idea the
place where the light goes through and
then the manifestation which comes out
and so i think that i think that in that
sense the eye is definitely
related to the wheel but i don't know if
if if it's
the idea of the window to the soul i
think when people say
that the eye is the window to the soul
it it has to do with
the fact that on the one hand
the eye is that one of the
that with which we give meaning to the
world is through
the eye and so the eye let's say the
invisible aspect of yourself
comes out of the eye you know when they
have these ancient i love i love when
people make fun of
old uh old ideas you know you see it all
the time
this idea that there's a ancient way of
understanding vision like that
there's a ray that comes out of the eye
and uh
and like touches and hits things and
then people materialists are always
making fun of that and think how stupid
it is right the idea that there's a ray
coming out of the eye
which understands it and it's like dude
there is a ray coming out of your eye
which
which which hits objects it's called
attention
it's it's really is a ray it's a focused
thing which focuses and then that's how
the world reveals itself like it's not
as
it's not a it's not a material ray it's
a
it's a ray of meaning which comes out of
your eye anyways so i think that in that
sense the
the eyes the window to the soul in the
sense that that the soul or the
invisible aspects will shine out of your
eye and then will
coalesce things into meaning but then
also i mean
when you look at someone you look into
their eyes you that's how you
you you are also able to look through
people's eyes in order to perceive their
intention
to perceive their you know whether
they're telling the truth
whether they are happy even their
emotions everything will come will
come out mostly through the eyes so
and you can see that like when you draw
for example you know
you can change someone's emotions just
by changing like the eyebrows right
so you can if you make a little
caricature you can help yeah
people can perceive different emotions
just by changing the shape of the
eyebrows around the eyes
um so that can help you understand how
we perceive
the fact that we can do that that you
can draw on a piece of paper a
face with different eyebrows and you
have a different perception of of
emotion
means that that's also what we perceive
in other people we have
that shortcut where we kind of see
meaning or see intention and all that in
the eyes
so all right guys i think
that we're done it's like every
every month i keep going longer and
longer so i don't know
how this is going to end if i if i'm
working up to
these like huge long three-hour things i
don't think i could do it but uh
so yeah so i would say thanks to
everybody thanks for
your attention thanks for your support
and uh
you know we've got a lot of good stuff
coming up in the future
none of this is is ending and hopefully
when
i am back in my house things are gonna
get
more streamlined this is this is gonna
be nicer
and uh it'll be better camera and better
lighting and all that stuff
so all right guys thank you for
everything thanks to our moderators to
jacob and brad
thanks to two more views don't forget to
to uh
to be there on october 31st um
and i will post the link to that on
twitter and on facebook and on youtube
so pay attention to that
and i'll talk to everybody next month
bye